bonjour ben quoi et merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sur rt france alors
dans un premier temps est-ce que les les
mesures prises par le premier ministre
et le gouvernement vous rassurera sur
l'hôpital en général rassure l'hôpital
d'une manière globale on peut dire qu'on
inclut mis en porte à faux les mesures
sont un peu tardives on était tous en
train d'observer ce qui se passait en
italie et pas de raison pour que ça ne
se produise pas en france donc
l'organisation a pris du retard chacun
essaye de faire au mieux chacun et
solidaire et mais on constate sur le
terrain que tout est trop tardif pour
cette fois efficaces dès aujourd'hui
alors votre témoignage est très
important à vous vivez cette crise du
coronavirus au quotidien vous à
l'hôpital
comment s'organise l'hôpital justement
racontez nous un peu votre votre
quotidien est ce que les services sont
prêts à organiser
c'est ce que je viens de dire sur la
région parisienne les messages jusqu'à
mercredi était plutôt très rassurant
pour un niveau collectif on avait beau
essayer de d'être plus alarmants en tant
que petit personnel en disant que
s'approchait que ça risque d'être
beaucoup plus grave que ce qu'on
imaginait et qui avaient des mesures qui
devaient déjà être en place au niveau de
la direction en général hospitalière sur
l'ensemble de la france avec mes
collègues dans les autres services
d'urgence c'était toujours on attend
c'est ton moment y'a pas de difficultés
majeures
on s'aperçoit que c'est pas le cas en
l'espace de trois quatre jours ça a été
très difficile à mettre en place dans
certains services
notre service y arrive encore
difficilement en trois quatre jours à
100 d'aidé matérielle jdd services déjà
occupé c'est très dur à mettre en place
quel est l'état d'esprit aujourd'hui du
personnel
soignant on a entendu plusieurs
personnes
à bout de force c'est votre cas
l'hôpital lariboisière
nous on est au tout début certaines
régions notamment grotesque sont déjà en
souffrance en écoutant leurs témoignages
et en échangeant un gars que ça nous
permet nous de nous préparer
psychologiquement on voit bien ça va
être difficile que si on n'est pas
solidaire pas prêts de manière
alternative on s'est préparé entre soi
on va dire entre paramédicaux pour
affronter ce qui arrive mais on est je
pense qu'on fait tout pour pour être
prêt et pouvoir faire ce pour quoi on
est dans ses petits services
est ce que vous vous pensez aussi que
ces mesures vont déjà permettre un
certain désengorgement des services
d'urgence notamment sur les zones déjà
avec des pics très élevé on claudia
c'est un petit peu dépassé déjà
l'affluence et est énorme
après c'est comme ce qu'on signaler et
qu'on a dénoncé tout au long de l'année
il n'y a pas de place on veut faire de
la place ça c'est pas d'un coup de
baguette magique
donc c'est un tetris qui est très
difficile à mettre en place donc les
urgences sont souvent déjà saturés et
les fameuses questions de tri sont déjà
en cours en fait il n'ya pas de lit qui
on met dans les vies et ça c'est aussi
la question qui s'est posée tout gagné
sur les autres pathologies quoi comment
vous vous envisagez
aujourd'hui l'avenir proche je sais que
c'est un peu compliqué comme comme
question mais quand vous vous projetez
qu'est ce que vous imaginez sur ce qui
va arriver à l'hôpital
on a discuté souvent avec mes collègues
c'est des premières journées jour bon a
priori on est tous assez d'accord d'être
très pragmatique le voir au jour le jour
même si on vous l'imaginez je pense
qu'on arrive on peut pas le faire on est
quelques-uns être des jeux et avoir vécu
la fameuse pas des canicules qui avait
déjà été très difficile les le public
était beaucoup plus spécifique la la
grande surprise en france et que on
parlait de personnes âgées en
réanimation
c'est pas le cas et c'est ce qui a
alerté les services de généraux de la
santé et à du tout la typologie des
passions ton village il est donc là
ajoute avant de se terminer
si vous aviez un message aux français
qui qui s'inquiètent un message pour
permettre au personnel de santé de faire
son travail dans les meilleures
conditions qu'elle serait justement ce
message à ce stade je pense qu'il est
nécessaire pour chacun d'eux de bien se
surveiller d'avoir bien pris
connaissance de la scientologie
les symptômes qui pourraient être graves
pour venir dans les moments où c'est
nécessaire à l'hôpital il faut préserver
tout le monde ne pas oublier que être
dans un service d'urgence doit être en
contact avec des gens qui sont vraiment
contaminés et si vous ne l'était pas il
vécut angoisses et c'est là où ils
avaient une chance a crû de match entre
d'être en contact avec le virus
merci beaucoup barbara coûts et d'avoir
répondu à nos questions 1 ce matin je
rappelle avec vous est infirmière de
nuit à l'hôpital lariboisière et membre
du collectif inter urgence merci
beaucoup et bon courage